one of the things is off the top but but
like there's a new way they do weigh-ins
now they know how they do the weigh-ins
at like eight or nine and then do like a
right fake weigh-in at like three or
four or whatever for the fans
i'm like oh really what is even the
point like i'm like okay if you want to
get us up at eight and nine tell the
fans we'll be there they'll be there
eight and nine yeah that's when you want
to do the weigh-ins let's just get it
done like what don't bring me back don't
let me bring you back for this stupid
thing number one number two
for me it really sucks because i i go to
sleep all my whole fight
prep i go sleep about two two three in
the morning
because i fight at nine o'clock at night
so nine thirty nine nine nine thirty at
night so i want my butt i don't want my
body getting ready to shut like if you
normally go go to sleep every day
at 10 o'clock
your body's shutting down instead of
putting chemicals out it's ready to shut
down you know 8 39 you know it's ready
to go to bed
i
i got i get up about 10 30 i go to sleep
about
about 2 30. so that was kind of my daily
schedule and i usually took a nap in the
afternoon after training
um
but
i don't i don't know if i would have
really liked having to get up
like i would i'd actually have to have
to cut weight before i went to bed
probably because i wouldn't want to get
up at five
to cut weight for
longer
it gives you longer to rehydrate though
like i was longer to rehydrate but but i
did i was that was an issue for me right
i didn't because because i only i didn't
cut i started cutting my water that
morning so i only cut water from for
like it's like be like you're doing like
you're going to do a regular workout
today right and just waiting a couple
extra hours to drink water it's you're
not going to get that dehydrated you
know
i lose 10 pounds i lose 10 pounds of
water but like
but the weight have to hold it off for
two or three hours it's not a big deal
right now now once you start holding
that overnight
i don't like holding it over that's one
of the reasons i do it that way i don't
like doing overnight like i don't like
start i wouldn't i like going to bed
deprived of water
what do you think about this
if uh if they decided
that
like at the little check-in station
where they they check your gloves and
they put the vaseline on your face and
stuff like like right before you get in
the octagon for the actual fight what do
you think if they weighed you at that
point so that you knew
stepping into the octagon precisely what
that person weighed i would be
fascinated to know how much how much
weight they put back on i think that
that'd be actually kind of cool for for
fans or like even even even just in the
locker room before they come out anytime
because you don't really give or take a
a few sips of water i mean if they just
when they came in and checked their
weight and just see what their weight is
the next day yeah but if they were i
mean they're already standing there for
like
on top of it
so you can see it up there that would be
kind of cool when the [ __ ] when the
see some of these differences like
especially some of these little guys man
i i'm impressed i'm still impressed when
they make that weight like right
you know when a little guy loses like 20
pounds i'm like dude how did you lose 20
pounds
before there was a day of weigh-in so i
made it but uh it was a
timing change so that's the guy who
doesn't mind doing it at eight and nine
in the morning but yeah oh yeah yeah
you're right as soon as i get it off
please let me step on a scale so
you weigh in at 205
and then what are you
by the time
i was about 2 15 probably by the time
you got into the ring you gained 10
pounds i gained it back out in like a
day that's why i walk around yeah yeah
because you just lost i lost it today
put it back on i'm crazy but i'm i'm
sorry then what's the point of the
weigh-in if
you guys wait when you fight anyway
it's a good question well the point is
that there's only everyone everyone made
a certain goal weight like you don't
have to so we don't have to walk around
we gotta went to a base point we have a
base everyone makes it to a base point
the day before that's an agreement like
i said so i don't care if you put on i
don't get to put on 34 pounds if you cut
so i had to cut 34 pounds to get there i
know that took it out of you so if
you're you're 34 pound heavier than me
you know but you you had to cut all that
you had to cut all that water and make
that weight as you're going to pay for
it tomorrow so you're paying for it
right like so so it does level the
playing field yeah it levels the playing
field because it's like a it's like for
different people like it's a
it's a like it's like deciding what
weight to stay at what weight to go down
to or if you go down a weight or stay up
a weight right and it comes down to like
what what's the best where where am i
the best where my i got the best
strength weight ratio like i where am i
the strongest
for that one for for my what my body
body type my weight my size yeah you
know and and it's just that's it's a
basic choice for people like everybody
makes it different like some people like
a lot of guys like some people don't
like to cut like i like to keep getting
now i get that i i just like to get to
where i'm about between 2 15 and 3 2 13
before i cut
now a lot of guys don't want to do that
like a lot of guys like to keep their
weight around 220 and cut down from
there
they're more comfortable cutting 15
pounds that's what makes them that makes
what makes them feel strongest and feels
best so that's right and that works for
me too like i don't care as long as you
as long as you made that weight we're
fair you know it's fair okay
i could have kept my weight up at 220 if
i wanted to sure and cut the same amount
of weight and been running bigger too
but i didn't want to because that i i
would it's like if i went everyone asked
me if i went if i went up to heavyweight
i still would have fought it like
i
220
218.
i
my body wouldn't when i carried it would
it would that would it would take a
while i would
maybe my third or fourth fight down the
road if i went heavy started going
heavyweight i would have started getting
bigger yeah but at that time like if i
decided to just go up for one fight
i would have been 218 because that's
where i was most comfortable fighting
right like if because i'd done anything
kickboxing before i was oh i'm going to
fight heavyweight so i might as well
just be 225. i felt like a slug i
started pushing my punches
yeah tired real fast there's a little
more weight to carry around so it makes
sense yeah do people do cocaine for
for our weight cuts or i guess they're
gonna drug test you for the fight yeah
they do
pride they [ __ ] do whatever that
seems like a strange way to wake up but
i guess you could i wonder like if if uh
if anybody is about to weigh in and
they're not gonna make weight have you
ever heard of anybody just [ __ ]
donating a pint of blood just to get
that last pound off that i have not
heard i don't i don't think that would
be a good idea
you want that blood unless you're gonna
put it back in after
transfusion yeah transfusions
armstrong [ __ ] weight cutting [ __ ]
dude
yeah we're on to something now
and thanks for clarifying that by the
way cut because i was always like what
the [ __ ] is the point but that makes
total sense what you're saying yeah i
mean and every everybody when you when
you agree to wait and if you make the
weight that's why i hate when these guys
show up like eight pounds over ten
pounds overall yeah right you show up
eight ten pounds over you didn't try
don't tell me yeah don't i don't i mean
i don't i i just got on the scale made
weight if you if you were having that
kind of a problem making weight call me
up
let's call talk to me hey
um hi bro if you want to fight i'm i
can't i can only make uh
you know
210 i'm not gonna make it let's do a
catch weight okay call let's go dana
we'll just do a catchwitch okay he does
not love catchweight he doesn't but but
i mean if you if if
it's between that and the fight you know
okay right right but if he because if
he's not gonna even try i don't want to
try i don't wanna i wanna have to make
way i don't wanna i wanna make weight
and then have him come in at two ten two
come over him weighing it at two fifteen
i weigh in at two or five it's like
that's not cool what happens when that
happens does the fight still happen if
they they ask that you have to accept it
if you want to yeah
you get a percentage of that first oh
okay okay yeah they'll renegotiate your
contract right down to the wire and
they'll say okay this guy's not making
weight but we're gonna give you 20 of
his purse well i think that i think
that's almost automatic to 20 percent of
his personality
even if he knocks you out you're getting
20 of what he'll make
correct okay all right yeah i think a
lot of i don't know you probably offered
a lot of different things depends on
sure
you know like if it's the guy trying to
make it in the ufc you say okay we'll
we'll give you we'll give you a if you
lose we'll bring it back anyway we're
not going to cut you for losing since
you should give up the weight right
right don't make negotiations you know
they won't make the fight don't
all come down to it you want to want to
fight yeah i mean i've accepted i i've
accepted a couple guys didn't make
weight before back in the day but i'm
like yeah
that was close enough they tried right
guys they're like is that okay like this
before there was commission oh wow
the statistics really show that people
who miss weight and come in heavier
went a lot like the the
like
your chances of winning coming in
heavier are greater
right so you're sacrificing twenty
thirty percent but you're probably gonna
win when you agree
when you agreed to fight a guy who
missed weight you are
like deliberately consciously taking
a disadvantage in the fight definitely
right and so as such you should get
uh financially compensated for sure i
agree
it's only fair it's like fighting with
steroids maybe not really but like
i mean you have a little bit of extra
weight behind you it kind of helps the
the cause yeah there are different
reasons
a lot of guys or maybe there's guys that
shouldn't be out that way
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you